[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a diario de copas el espacio
de france 24 para seguir el desarrollo
de la copa américa y la eurocopa
estos son los titulares
resultado histórico suiza impacto sobre
la hora y luego venció a francia en
penales para avanzar a los cuartos de
final de la presente edición de la
eurocopa de naciones tenemos un análisis
y reporte de este país
la roja vibra la selección española de
fútbol volvió a anotar 5 goles por
segunda vez en el torneo y superó a
croacia en los octavos de final de la
euro 2020 el conjunto de luis enrique se
medirá a suiza el próximo viernes en san
petesburgo tenemos reacciones
todo definido argentina venció a bolivia
y uruguay derrotó a paraguay para cerrar
la primera fase del grupo y con ello la
copa américa asia lista para los duelos
de cuartos de final que comenzarán el
próximo viernes analizamos los partidos
como es costumbre le damos la bienvenida
a nuestra invitada sara castro directora
del diario 'as' en colombia bienvenidas
ahora como estas hola luis un gusto
vamos a ver cómo ponemos en palabras una
de las jornadas más emocionantes de
fútbol de los últimos tiempos por
supuesto que sí sobre ello más adelante
tendremos reportes de este país con
nuestra compañera natalia ruiz giraldo
pero empecemos con los resultados de esa
jornada que ya adelantaba sara las
selecciones de francia y suiza
ofrecieron un partido que terminó con
empate a tres goles en 120 minutos
nuevamente el conjunto francés se
comenzó abajo en el marcador pero mostró
la capacidad para reaccionar y darle
vuelta al mismo gracias a las
anotaciones de karim benzema y paul
pogba sin embargo suiza pudo empatar con
las dianas de haris seferovic y mario
gavranovic sobre los minutos finales en
penales
yann sommer se erigió como el héroe al
detener el penal cobrado por kilian
mbappe
será un torneo difícil para francia
primero una fase de grupos muy compleja
con equipos de renombre portugal
alemania hungría pero ahora se viene
esta situación de suiza podemos hablar
de sorpresa dentro de este partido de
los campeones del mundo se espera que
siempre ganen pero por eso el fútbol es
inagotable desde el juego hay que decir
que deschamps y se equivocó en el
planteamiento del partido salió con una
línea de tres que poco le ayuda a la
idea y si dejó claro lo dejó en
evidencia muchos problemas defensivos
del equipo y ahí estaba suiza un equipo
insistente y muy eficaz que aprovechó
esas oportunidades luego hugo llorís
salvas de matchpoint porque era fue un
penal atajado en un momento clave y del
minuto 56 al 74 vemos las toneladas de
calidad que tiene francia vimos
los dos goles de benzema que son una
belleza el primero un control
excepcional el segundo una jugada
colectiva muy bonita y el tercer gol de
pogba un gol de media distancia para uno
de los mejores jugadores del torneo
y suiza que nunca bajó los brazos
insistió insistió los llevó a la
prórroga y luego en los penales le toqué
errarlo a killing mbappe y por supuesto
y los ojos están puestos en deschamps
porque cuando se tiene una plantilla de
este tipo y no se logran resultados o no
se cumple con este propósito por
supuesto el primer señalado va a ser el
entrenador así es la situación en estos
momentos en francia pero escuchemos el
reporte de nuestra compañera natalia
ruiz
giraldo de este país
sui sabe la vida en rosa' tras derrotar
a francia el archifavorito y campeona
del mundo y asegurar un paso a cuartos
de final de esta eurocopa en un partido
que se vio al borde del suspenso con los
suiza que abrió el marcador en el minuto
15 gracias a un cabezazo de seferovic de
hecho tuvo para el segundo gracias a una
penalti pero el disparo de rodríguez fue
atajado por hugo llorís el capitán
francés y de hecho a partir de ese
momento parecía que francia despertaba
porque karim benzema marcó un doblete en
dos minutos y luego vino el tercer gol
un golazo de media distancia de paul
pogba a 15 minutos de el final que
parecía sentenciar el partido sin
embargo la zaga francesa sufrió
muchísimo a lo largo de este partido muy
criticado ese planteamiento de los tres
defensores de división y bueno suiza
encontró los espacios aprovechó los
errores y logró descontar a 10 minutos
del final y sobre todo empatar el
partido en el minuto 90 del encuentro se
fue a el alargue pero sobre todo se
definió ya desde el punto penal y fue
kilian mbappe el número días de francia
el último en cobrar y el único que falló
su disparo que terminó en manos de
el arquero suizo y bueno los suizos que
logran esta victoria histórica y ahora
disputarán ante españa su pase a
semifinal
y sobre ello vamos a escuchar qué fue lo
que dijo el seleccionador francés tras
concluir este encuentro
a pesar de todo esto no podemos pensar
demasiado en esto porque nos servirá de
excusa
pero ahora los últimos campeones del
mundo están afuera duele pero tenemos
que ser mi foro etc
y seguimos con más de la eurocopa porque
otro partido de octavos de final que
acaparó la atención fue el efectuado
entre españa y croacia la selección
española se impuso sobre la prórroga con
marcador de 5 goles por 3 luego de que
croacia pudo anotar dos goles para
empatar a tres en los 90 minutos
reglamentarios por escuchemos lo que
dijo el seleccionador español luis
enrique sobre este partido lo que sí me
ha llamado mucho la atención y me ha
gustado muchísimo ha sido los últimos
cinco minutos de la prueba cuando las
dos aficiones se han levantado y ha
empezado a aplaudir a los croatas
y valorando el esfuerzo el sacrificio de
los 22 jugadores que había en el terreno
de los 20 228 34 que habían participado
me ha parecido un gesto muy bonito en un
deporte tan maravilloso como es el
fútbol reconociendo el esfuerzo y el
espectáculo que han dado las dos
selecciones
luis enrique agradeciéndole en la
afición todo ese respaldo pero hablar de
españa particularmente comenzó lento el
torneo con muchas dudas pero ha
demostrado que ofensivamente está muy
bien quizás los problemas se están
generando la defensa este es un partido
histórico para españa porque tuvo que
superar pruebas emocionales desde lo
colectivo y lo individual y siempre fue
fiel a su idea y eso a la hora de
evaluar procesos es muy importante es
fundamental en una y simón y morata que
estaban casi condenados se visten de
héroes y pedrito también que estuvo
involucrado en la primera de la primera
el error de ese gol también hace una
prórroga espectacular
yo creo que vimos un partido de fútbol
valiente y de reivindicaciones y eso
siempre vamos
como lo decía luis enrique y creo que
además no se puede evaluar el desempeño
de españa sin hablar de croacia lo de
croacia es espectacular porque
mantuvieron ese espíritu dalí que
también desde el desde el banco hace
cambios muy importantes adelanta las
líneas moody que se ejerce ese rol de
liderazgo y sin duda pase lo que pase en
la siguiente fase del torneo españa
llega con un envión anímico y sobre todo
una convicción en la idea que
seguramente los va a ser muy
competitivos por supuesto que sí un gran
desgaste el hecho por croacia durante
los últimos minutos de el tiempo
reglamentario pero la jornada de hoy en
la euro continúa ya que hoy se cierran
los octavos de final ya está en marcha
el partido entre las selecciones de
inglaterra y alemania que permanece sin
goles ya sobre el minuto 61 más adelante
se estarán midiendo las representaciones
de suecia y ucrania ambos ganadores
chocarán entre ellos en los cuartos de
final del próximo sábado que además del
duelo entre suiza y españa
ya confirman los partidos entre la
república checa y dinamarca además de
bélgica e italia
así pasamos a notas de la copa américa
que ayer cerró la fase de grupos en este
caso la selección de argentina consolidó
su etiqueta de favorita para disputar la
final al derrotar a bolivia con marcador
de cuatro goles por uno en otro
compromiso y gracias a un tanto de
edison cavani la selección de uruguay
superó a su par de paraguay y finalizó
como segundo en este grupo para
argentina termina dominando el grupo a
que parecía complejo por los rivales que
tenía que enfrentar pero ya podemos
decir que cuenta con todas las
herramientas para ir a pelear ese título
que tanto anhela dio en el mes argentina
había dejado dudas sobre todo por la
manera como manejaba algunos momentos de
los partidos pero para mí hay tres cosas
claves en este equipo uno que tienen una
plantilla muy amplia que le da variantes
al entrenador dos que lionel scaloni que
había sido bastante cuestionado sobre la
idoneidad de su hoja de vida para
agarrar este cargo lleva 17 partidos sin
perder 10 triunfos 7 empates y eso creo
que lo pone en una muy buena posición y
también
de mes y el nivel futbolístico ya lo
conocemos sabemos que hace cosas que
otros no hacen y que con eso ya podría
vivir del fútbol pero también el nivel
de compromiso y de competitividad que le
estamos viendo ilusiona de carona
posible final con brasil que podría
darse el 10 de junio en el estadio
maracaná enfrentando al otra la otra
gran figura del torneo como es neymar
ayer la selección de bolivia quedó
eliminada pero escuchemos lo que dijo 6a
farías sobre la participación del
combinado del altiplano
sin desmerecer nuestro grupo tiene
rivales históricos y muy difíciles y
todo el mundo los conoce la verdad
afrontamos los partidos de la mejor
manera así que estamos conformes y
satisfechos por el aporte de todos los
jugadores
escuchamos ahí era a lionel scaloni en
este caso pero como lo habíamos
adelantado uruguay venció a paraguay por
la mínima y se quedó con el segundo
puesto del grupo a pero escuchemos lo
que dijo oscar tabares director técnico
de la selección de uruguay
esperamos que el próximo partido que
jugaremos contra colombia estemos en
mejor forma y esperar un resultado
histórico ahora no hay otro resultado
distinto a ganar para quedarse en la
copa
nos está acostumbrando uruguay a esto a
venir de menos a más en cada uno de los
terrenos si la verdad es que a uruguay
le ha faltado generación de juego y
efectividad pero siempre el maestro
tabárez que sabe dominar estas crisis el
equipo se recupera desde su tranquilidad
y también desde la mística de lo que
ellos son yo creo que uruguay está
viviendo una evolución desde su
identidad de su desde su adn y estamos
viendo cómo se incorporan nuevos
conceptos creo que es un firme candidato
una vez más y un rival complicadísimo
para colombia' la siguiente ronda
muchísimas gracias ahora por tus
comentarios a lo largo de este programa
a todos ustedes por estar junto a
nosotros continúen con más de la
programación de france 24 y de france 24
punto com